[Music]
so thank you everyone for doubling down
on your Google next 19 experience
showing up on the very last day for the
very first session considering that
somewhat over achievement we've teed up
a session that both showcases GCPs
commitment to partner driven innovation
as well as showcasing some key solutions
delivered by our data center and sd1
solution partners together we've been
hard at work solving some of the key
challenges that are only just emerging
with regards to the enterprise network
you've probably noticed that your
network is changing at least in four key
ways an increasingly distributed hybrid
networking set of assets as well as a
need to go multi cloud for a number of
different reasons to build preferred
solutions picking Best of Breed services
you know to deliver them in a reliable
manner and Google promotes this we're
very open to that use case and we know
that it is a use case that is in in
proliferation all of which needs to come
together in a highly performant and
reliable manner with security being
distributed all across the board we have
four solutions today that we'll be
showcasing starting with Andrew Leung
from Citrix showcasing their sd1
solution followed by bill long at
Equinix and then by matt simpson at mega
port and lastly Manav Mishra from silver
peak systems again with an ST Ron
solution so let me transition over we
will have five minutes at the at the end
to host a Q&A session but without
further ado let me invite Andrew to come
talk about the Citrix estaban solution
Thank You Rohit good morning everyone
it's a privilege to be here to share
with you a little bit about
citrix the company our SD wine solution
as well as our partnership with Google
specifically Google cloud and so I'm
Andy Leung I run the SD way and
marketing program for Citrix and well
some of you may know about Citrix as a
company some of you may not and so let
me just start off with a brief intro
we're a cloud computing company we've
been around for 30 years and we're
probably most known for having created
the eicha the independent computing
architecture protocol for virtualization
for desktops servers and applications
and so we too have been on this journey
towards a cloud and along the way we've
actually partnered with over 400,000
enterprises across leading industry
verticals and you can see some of the
samples here we have partnerships with
large organizations institutions across
manufacturing healthcare retail
financial and banking as well as some of
the top cloud computing platforms and so
our portfolio while we're known for
applications and what's called the
digital workspace we also have a
networking portfolio and what is that
comprised of well you've heard perhaps
over the course of this past week what
some of these solutions and technologies
entail but effectively they traverse the
areas of SD Wan's security as well as
application delivery or ADC as some of
you may know that from a data center
perspective now we also have analytic
solutions which also ingest the data
across these applications systems as
well as a network and actually
contextualizes that so that IT teams
like yourselves can actually figure out
how to best optimize your network your
cloud solutions as well as the end-user
experience now some of you may have
heard about SD WAN
and as a technology unto itself there
are various components fundamental
components things like routing when
optimization application controls
security as well as path management and
control
now we have those capabilities and I'm
not going to stand here and market to
this audience here but we've decided to
actually take a different approach to SD
win both in terms of how we've developed
a solution as well as how we continue to
innovate on it and it's really taking
the end-user
and that experience into account and so
we're focus from an SDRAM perspective on
delivering a superb exceptional
experience for these applications
whether they reside in SAS environments
in virtual environments or in various
Aya's and Pass environments we obviously
need to take into account security and
so we make security easy so we offer
solutions that actually protect the
assets applications data users across
network and cloud in addition when it
comes to the journey to cloud we make it
easier in that we offer flexible on
ramps for customers to extend their
enterprise branches and environments
over to the cloud and along with that we
offer automation because simplification
without automation well really those are
just words so how do we deliver this
unique experience so what we have that's
built into our solution is what's called
a application control engine and so if
you think about an IT team that is
trying to get visibility into what's
going across the network what's being
consumed from the cloud they may have
visibility into something like G suite
they may have visibility into
applications and protocols well
ultimately for IT to really be effective
they're going to want to have granular
visibility into is the traffic real-time
in nature is it something via chat
Google Hangouts is it a chat session is
it a voice session is it a Google Drive
sharing session and be able to
effectively detect automatically
classify and therefore apply priorities
to those sessions and along with that
our application control engine has that
capability to detect and optimize well
over 4,500 applications including many
of the
components of G sweet and so this along
with our networking capabilities allow
our customers actually deliver what we
refer to as that always-on workspace
experience we also employed capabilities
like deep packet inspection and when
optimization to optimize bandwidth and
the traffic going across the wide area
network so this week we're pleased to
announce a series of new capabilities on
Google cloud platform one of them is
Citrix SD LAN for GCP and so this is
currently in field trial this will be
generally available in just a few weeks
here and effectively what we're doing is
we're making our SD weigh-in appliance
the virtual instance of it available on
the GCP marketplace and so with this
customers will be able to effectively
download checkout if you will and then
spin up within a VPC a Citrix SD LAN
appliance and so with that configuration
branch's data centers can be easily
connected to GCP resources with high
availability with all the application
performance and quality that I
referenced earlier we have capabilities
like dual ended QoS and last mile
awareness so that if there are changing
bandwidth conditions our network can
adapt to that again in the interests of
delivering that better user experience
and then we've also got unique
capabilities like sub-second failover of
links and so if customers in remote
locations in the case of retail they're
using a dedicated internet access
connection via cable or DSL they can use
4G LTE as a backup and because this
failover occurs in less than seconds
really for the most part there's no
disruption to the user experience so
this is really just a element of our
broader multi cloud solution where we
give customers optionality we
effectively give them choice if they
want to go and connect to GCP we
recognize that it's a heterogeneous
environment so if they want to go to
you alternate cloud platforms they have
that capability they can also when it
comes to SAS we offer capabilities that
utilize a private backbone to enable the
same level of resiliency in connecting
to let's say a workday or a
salesforce.com cloud as well and we've
also got partnerships with the likes of
a clinics where if customers want a
neutral cloud exchange in order to multi
cloud into whether GCP or any of the
other cloud platforms they have that
capability as well and lastly with
respect to alternate backbones and I
recognize this gets a little bit geeky
here but as a overlay to an underlay and
what does that mean basically it means
an alternate cloud backbone so we have
partnerships with companies like tur
ideon in the event that customers really
want to take it to that level of
sophistication as far as fine-tuning
their networks and so with respect to
security we recognize that the attack
vectors are expanding and so we have
built-in security controls within our
appliances we have essentially stateful
application firewalls we have options
via partnerships to actually bring
onboard next-generation firewalls as
well as if customers want to deploy Sdn
firewall capabilities within cloud
environments such as GCP they can do
that as well
and then lastly because a lot of traffic
is becoming increasingly consumed via
SAS and via the public internet we have
partnerships with the likes of Z scaler
Palo Alto and others that actually
provide cloud-based secure web gateway
capabilities and so lastly with regards
to the simplification and the automation
we have a cloud base management solution
that actually spins up resources not
only in branches and data centers but
also can connect to cloud solutions like
some of those we looked at we have the
ability to automatically via a few mouse
clicks bring up connections to security
solutions as well as with productivity
Suites
and and so what we're doing is over time
providing more choice for customers to
actually connect you more and more
productivity Suites to more cloud
solutions and so at the end of the day
it's about as customers go on this
journey to cloud offering them this
choice but for the most part the
application experience that is going to
keep their business up and running so
that's what I have to share with you
this morning we've got a booth in the
South Hall here I believe we are on the
left of the main entrance and close to
the snack bar so if anyone has any
questions or wants to get a little bit
more into detail on our SD win or
networking solutions feel free to drop
by excuse me
and also we've got some revolving
theater sessions as well and so we will
be covering SD win as well as other
elements of our networking solution
and lastly Rohith and team have actually
put out a blog this week on Google cloud
networking and so I encourage you all to
check that out that's it thank you good
morning everybody I'm Bill long with
Equinix I'm in charge the
interconnection products at Equinix if
I'd known this was the setup I would
have had some Equinix branded you know
popcorn that you guys could have and/or
you know it's some Junior Mints you
could throw at me if you didn't like
what I was gonna say but unfortunately I
I didn't know that so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna give given where Equinix
sits in the ecosystem I'm gonna really
highlight sort of what we're seeing in
the market and how people are are
enabling cloud connectivity so no good
presentation these days
starts without a nod to digital
disruption and like all sort of cliches
there's always an ounce of truth in it
so so we are seeing people are really
getting their infrastructure ready for
digital disruption across all different
verticals obviously manufacturing move
it to the industrial internet
transportation with rideshare you know
across the board it's happening across
all verticals I mean what they're doing
is they're trying to distribute their
architecture to be ready such that
they're there they're there
infrastructure is ready for the digital
transformation
so I mentioned that Equinix it's an
interesting spot for us to be able to
observe what what enterprises are really
doing so we have 200 data centers around
the world 52 different markets and the
data centers are a little bit different
than your it's not just a big warehouse
full of servers our sweet spot is is
providing solutions and ecosystems where
people can actually connect to each
other so if you look at the cloud edge
nodes that are deployed globally out
there about 50% of those are in Equinix
data centers so the rest of the industry
splits the other 50% so what that gives
us visibility into is who's connecting
to who what are they doing with it
how are they using it what are the use
cases they're doing and so what we've
done is we've analyzed just over about
800 800 different enterprises to look at
what are the trends that we were that
we're seeing for how people are
transforming their infrastructure to be
ready for digital transformation and so
what we've noticed is there are four
very distinct steps that that folks are
going through and typically they're in
this exact order so if you're an
enterprise customer and you're wondering
well how do i how do I enable this
transformation of making my
infrastructure ready for digital
transformation there's this is sort of
the roadmap that we're seeing or if
you're a vendor who's coming up with
solutions these are the types of these
the steps that we're seeing enterprises
take in order to be ready for that
transformation so step one is typically
they'll want to optimize their network
so typically you know applications will
be hosted in their basement and then
then then all of their users will be
using a wide area network to get to
those applications the first step is to
distribute those applications out
optimize your ran is is is is step
number one so take those applications
instead of get those applications closer
to the end users to reduce latency to
actually drive down cost so that that's
step one typically once enterprises have
moved that that have optimized their ran
to distribute out their applications
they then use those nodes to connect out
to enable a multi hybrid cloud
architecture and so we'll double click
on that one a little bit here in a
minute and then then once they have sort
of the distributed architecture
connected out to the clouds they fortify
that with a pretty row
security parameter our perimeter once
that security perimeter is there we
typically see them move a lot more of
their data close to those applications
so that's the the rough progression of
what we see when we look at these 800
customers of how they're there on this
journey double-clicking down into the
the hybrid multi cloud so what what do
folks care about when they're moving
when they're taking that second step for
hybrid multi cloud number one they care
what clouds are available so what we see
typically is that if a customer's
connected to one cloud they are most
likely going to connect to at least two
other clouds so having that you know
cloud availability is is absolutely
critical
we have I mentioned sort of the edge
nodes that Equinix has available GCI is
available in Equinix locations in 22
different metros so so that's important
the second big step is performance so
you want to make sure that when you're
deploying your infrastructure it's in a
place that that's gonna have the best
performance for connecting into the
clouds that you care about as well as
provides the option to scale both from
performance standpoint and a cost
standpoint so a pattern that we see from
a lot of customers is they will start on
cloud exchange so cloud exchange is a
platform that you can set up virtual
connections to multiple clouds but once
that starts to scale to a 10 gig or
multi 10 gig connections having the
option to pull that off to a cross
connect is it is a really important
capability to have both for performance
as well as for a cost standpoint so
pulling out over to a cross connect and
have that option available is really
important to customers and there we have
nine of the 11 regions of the of the GCI
regions are available in in X today I
think the next closest competitor has
has like two locations available and
then the third option of course is is
ease of use and flexibility and that
that means both technical ease of use as
well as in flexibility as well as
commercial flexibility so being able to
set up connections you know obviously
when you're using multi cloud being able
to connect into and out of you know move
workloads around dynamically you can set
up connections tear those connections
down in a very flexible way is super
important
so a little bit of a double-click on
that through cloud exchange you can set
up connections tear them down to any
location anywhere in the world so if
you're in in Sydney and you want you
have a workload that needs to access
Google cloud in Ashburn or somewhere you
can use cloud exchange to set that up or
for redundancy but again you can set
that up tear those down in a very sort
of flexible architecture to quick use
cases that we're seeing at the the first
and probably by far the the predominant
use case that we're seeing is connecting
on-premise unpromising
out to cloud assets so being able to
have the the the infrastructure that you
have in the cloud appear on your
corporate network such that you can you
can have applications in your own
private enterprise when be able to
access those those assets and have them
appear on their same private network
that's the sort of prime use case number
one use case number two is we're
starting we're actually in in limited
availability with this capability now
we're gonna be rolling it out where you
can spin up to be able to do multi cloud
in use cases so whether you have a data
set that you want to move out of AWS and
into GCI or if it's an application where
you want to have compute in one cloud
and you want to have analytics in
another cloud being able to set up a
virtual router and move data into and
out of multiple clouds it is also a
second use case and you can go to our
booth and we can show you a demo of
exactly what that's gonna gonna look
like as well so with that this is
information about how to come and find
us and I'll be around after the session
for a couple minutes as well thank you
guys
[Applause]
okay good morning all right I promise
it's gonna be close to a blockbuster hit
today but again I think we need the
popcorn but I'm going to talk a little
bit about mega port our vision is to
simplify connectivity when you're
looking at I guess Rohith was mentioning
before multi-cloud and and also bill it
can be very complex and I guess our
vision is that we want to ensure that
you are focused on getting the best
performance out of your applications and
so our vision is to simplify that
connectivity and abstract some of the
the complexity out of getting connected
to cloud but it's not only getting
connected to cloud and I think bill
touched on this as well it's a rich deep
ecosystem out there to get of course a
full end-to-end solution a mega port of
course is about connecting not only the
data centers but the network providers
managed service providers and a full
ecosystem out there we have thirteen
hundred and fifty customers that connect
today across four hundred and twenty
five data centers which which of those
are eighty two of those are unique data
center operators so we do have Equinix
and and cyrus one and sixth here in
interaction and flek central and digital
reality of course so what's unique about
I guess our offering is that we we
believe it should be fast it should be
with ease and you should have choice
because at the end of the day you need
to be focused on those applications so
we touched on where over the last five
years mega ports been building out layer
to software-defined network and open a
neutral plat interconnection platform
and over the last five years we've been
building out to those data centers a
redundant network
across all of those facilities and and
generally that's where those service
providers live all those interconnection
points and so over that the past five
years our customers been connecting at
layer two but what we have been seeing
is customers are wanting that cloud to
cloud connectivity and whilst they might
have infrastructure or that hybrid
scenario with layer two they're also
looking at connecting cloud to cloud
without going and procuring network
hardware and space and power so across
the 425 you can establish a service or a
network a port with our particular
service anywhere across the globe it
takes a couple of minutes to provision
and you can also scale that bandwidth in
real time so I'm going to touch a little
bit about mega port cloud router it's a
solution that our customers were coming
to us about and it was I have my data
center I've got my own pram and I'm
connecting to cloud but now I want to
look at connecting the two cloud
endpoints so in this scenario it's a
private layer three service and you can
establish this at a one gig
two-and-a-half gig or even ten gig if
you like and this is a managed layer
three connectivity service so what we
have done with this virtual router is
abstracted some of that configuration
and it also allows you to if you don't
have your own a s or your own IP then
this device will actually manage that
for you and automatically assign so in a
typical scenario a customer may come to
us and say okay I want to have a little
bit of mixture of um pram and then cloud
with a hybrid scenario and then they'll
also look at cloud to cloud so I'm using
this diagram as a bit of an overview of
a virtual router I've stood it up in a
particular zone and then I've got that
variety of multiple clouds services
there so in this case we do provide the
service
across both GCP across 23 of the
interconnect points across the globe and
we also provide direct peering which is
the layer 3 service which gives you
access to the Google's public resources
as well and so I wanted to share with
you oh it's not working that well on
this particular screen but a typical
customer scenario might have media and
entertainment is a great one for
animation and rendering they're looking
for burstable traffic it's seasonal and
they may have their infrastructure in LA
and they'll establish a low to port with
us and they'll connect to multiple
different services within the west coast
of the US but what if they had their
application that are in the East Coast
and they didn't want to they wanted to
stand that up pretty quickly and the
storage and compute might be an AWS but
they're looking to get access to some of
the analytics on GCP with this mega port
cloud router you can spin up the virtual
device within a couple of minutes and
have virtual cross connections between
GE CP and AWS so private layer 3
connection it doesn't touch the public
Internet and then if you want to you can
actually connect those to our services
back to west coast if you want to for a
one-off migration in that particular
scenario and then you can turn that
device off after you've used it whether
it be a month a day or a year or even an
hour the choice is yours
we talked a little bit about the
application and seasonal and bursting of
traffic and what we've done with mega
port is we've aligned our business model
similar to cloud so you can actually
spin up your connection private
connection from one megabit right up to
100 gigabits if you like and you can
actually do that on demand and in this
scenario we are particularly seasonal
traffic you can manipulate those speeds
whenever you
into whether it be on a weekend whether
it be an evening and will only bill you
for what you actually consume we've got
a couple of customers particularly media
and entertainment they're actually
chasing some of that cheap storage and
compute particularly whatever provider
that might be we've had scenarios where
a customer might go from Toronto right
down to Ashburn and with a virtual cross
connection they could do that for a
month
and what's really important is Thomas
talked about an open ecosystem this week
and with mega port we've got that
neutral platform that you can connect to
multiple services across four hundred
and twenty five data centers across 120
cloud on-ramps across multiple cloud
providers and it's really important that
there's with Google there's 58 points of
presence they've got one largest
networks but with mega port Eurex you're
actually connecting from 425 points of
those locations so we're extending the
reach of GCP and bring it to the
doorstep to you as the enterprise user
and that's really important from a
performance from and getting the best
out of your application I think that's
pretty much it so we actually do of
course like everyone here we've got a
booth I'll be I'll be here for the rest
of the sort of morning and look forward
to discussing it with you thanks very
much
[Applause]
let me get this thing straight
hi this is Manav
I work for silver pika run product
management for silver peak for those of
you who don't know silver peak solar
peak is a company that has been around
for about a decade or so we focused
earlier on on ran optimization and a few
years ago we were one of the early
vendors early products in the space
that's now known as software-defined
wide area networks so why are we
different from other products and
services in the space part of the reason
is we have always taken a business
intent driven an apps driven approach to
networking so essentially what we
realized was enterprises you know small
businesses medium businesses customers
cared more about taking their business
intent and business policies and
transforming them into network
configurations network policies firewall
rules you know routing policies and
whatnot and what we provide is an
abstraction to all of that a simple
abstraction that can take a
human-readable a human prescriber both
policy for the treatment an enterprise
admin wants the application of the
service to have and get that translated
all the way down to the to the router to
the data plane in terms of actionable
policies what we achieve by doing that
is the quality of experience so as we
know as the world is progressively
moving towards SAS and SAS applications
the quality of performance of those
applications is largely dictated by the
ability of the networking infrastructure
to know when to intelligently break out
the traffic to which public cloud
presence to send the traffic to and to
afford the right performance for audio
and video over Internet
we our solution is also built on the
notion of continuous adaptation and what
I mean by that is it's a self-learning
and a self-driving network so we looking
at the data that flows in through the
customers network we automate a bunch of
different things on behalf of the
customer a we develop the learning of
packet identification application
identification and we have this
technology called first packet IQ
technology which can looking at the very
first packet over a new application type
it can detect what the application is
and then decide based on the
identification what paul is
corresponding policy to apply to it
whether that application or that packet
needs to be backhaul all the way back to
HQ or to the data center or it needs to
break out locally and we are
continuously learning it at every node
at every router in the network and we
use that to to make the network more
intelligent and more adaptive finally
what we also realized working with the
customers is that node 2 customers are
like there are some customers who want
to overhaul their in entire existing
infrastructure they want to take what
they have you know put in place over the
last 10 years and move to this new world
of software-defined wide area networks
and then there are customers who
actually want an Estevan solution that
will play nicely that will fit in with
the existing network so we call it green
field or brown field deployments and for
brown field deployments we need to have
a solution that supports a lot of the
existing protocol infrastructure that
customers have in place so things like
bgp OSPF things like multicast virtual
routing and forwarding capabilities so
we have a unified solution that brings
an the best of software-defined wide
area networks and makes it set in you
know with existing infrastructure so
that customers any type of customer can
use a product and be successful our
success has been recognized by Gartner
so gata has you know started publishing
what we call the Magic Quadrant for the
van edge
has a name for every area technology
that we you know call by a particular
name Gardner has its own name for it so
Software Defined wide area networks are
you know it's called a vantage by
Gardner we are one of the three leaders
in the Magic Quadrant or I want to talk
a little bit about a platform and then
talk about how we enable success for
Google cloud customers so a platform
essentially is all unified route first
you know stack which has application
visibility and control this is the
packet detection identification
intelligent breakout that I talked about
it has routing capabilities so
essentially you know inter inter playing
nicely with OSPF bgp multicast vrf name
it it has van optimization so our
companies root roots were in van
optimization so van optimization is a
built-in integrated feature so for
customers who want van up and there is
still a lot of customers who have their
own own private cloud offerings who need
van optimization it's easy to enable
using our product and network security
so we have built in firewalls and
built-in segmentation that customers can
use so that they don't need to have yet
another appliance to afford these
capabilities for the network and all of
these are built into what we call the
edge connect appliance the unity edge
connect appliance now this appliance is
available you know the software is
available in a virtualized form so if
you want to run it on Prem on a
hypervisor you could do so it's
available in the cloud we are the only
product out there which is available on
all major public clouds so you can
actually go to Google marketplace as
your marketplace AWS marketplace or a
climatic marketplace and you can easily
get it and deploy it in a V PC of your
choice and we it also you know comes
with silver peak hardware so for your
branch offices where you want you know
local point of presence for the software
in a branch office you can actually get
hardware and software combo from silver
peak so this is essentially a data plane
this is where the magic actually happens
but how does the data plane know what to
do and how does the data plane know you
know
what policies are being configured by
the user and that happens through what
we call the orchestration plane so we
have a centralized business driven
orchestration solution
I think it's available in three
different forms it's available in a SAS
forum we call it orchestrated as a
service so we run it in a public cloud
presence and as a customer you know
think of it just like a SAS product you
can login to the portal
you get access to your orchestration for
your network and you can manage and
configure your network from day it's
also available on Prem so you can
actually if you have your own on Prem
infrastructure all you need to do is
have a hypervisor layer and deploy this
OVA or you know or the hypervisor format
of your choice onto onto your existing
infrastructure or you can run it just
like with the virtual appliance you can
run it in a V PC in any of the major
public clouds so you can run it on
Google Amazon Microsoft Oracle so this
this this is sort of the net-net of what
our overall you know product looks like
we also have integrated service chaining
platform built into other products so by
which if you want to intelligently
breakout traffic to a security service
provider like Z scalar or a Palo Alto or
a checkpoint I'm going to cover that in
a subsequent slide the list of our
partners you could do so and the
orchestration to Z scalar is automated
so essentially all you need to do is you
need to in the UI you just need to
define the policy for traffic you could
say hey all the traffic that's going to
my corporate websites send it back to
the data center and anything that's
going out to the internet send it to Z
scalar and then behind the scenes we
work with Z scalar we find out the local
points of presence for Z scalar that are
closest to that branch office and we
automate the tunnel creation between all
sites and the corresponding C scalar
points of presence
worldwide for the customer with just one
click we also have flow through
operations essentially everything that
we do in the product is available by our
REST API so it's a cloud first approach
to building the product so like if you
want to have access to the detailed
statistics and analytics and log logs
that we have we make it available to our
customers and we have customers using
that and you know syncing it into their
own data analytics systems and data
warehousing systems we have a Splunk
connector for a bunch of our enterprise
customers who use it import the data
from our systems into Splunk and then
they do their own detail analysis and
insight gathering from that the unity H
Connect appliance I'm just going to
quickly cover this as I said it's
available in a physical virtual and
cloud based form it you know it runs
unity boost which is our an optimization
feature it has fast packet detection the
one thing I wanted to touch up over here
is we have zero touch branch deployments
so we have zero touch provisioning and
zero touch configuration so essentially
you could you know if you're an IT admin
and you want to send a replacement box
to another into a branch office in your
in your organization but you want to pre
configure all the policies for it you
could actually just use user scripts
user REST API speak and figure the box
and when the branch office gets the box
all they have to do is open it up and
plug in the cables and it's good to go
or you can use Xero touch provisioning
which is you know we ship a new box to
the branch office the branch office you
know connects the box two cables goes
into the orchestrator Orchestrator shows
that a new device or new york lines has
been detected and then you let the
orchestrator or orchestrate it on on
your behalf so essentially think of it
as the modern pixel or iPhone experience
where you just have to log in with your
you know username and ID and the
policies and data that you have for that
particular device automatically are
provisioned through the cloud so these
are a list of
nurse you know as I said we work with a
variety of them you know parallel to Z
scalar checkpoint force point semantics
the list is endless
coming on to how we enable success for
Google and Google cloud customers as I
mentioned our virtual appliance is
available on Google cloud today you
could give it a try
we have customers we have quite a few
customers who are who have deployed and
are using silver peak on Google cloud
today and they are using silver peak on
Google cloud in two different deployment
models so we have customers who are new
in the journey to Google cloud or who
basically want to enable cloud on-ramp
for a particular organization between
the their enterprise so they basically
deploy they create a single VPC on
Google Cloud and then deploy RH connect
appliance onto that and then we also
have more complicated and complex
deployments where customers have a large
presence on Google cloud and they have a
bunch of different apps services you
know data sets residing on Google cloud
and they want access to all of these to
the rest of the enterprise and what they
do is they deploy silver peak on Google
cloud use a load balancer and use that
is to serve all the different VP C's
that they have in the infrastructure so
the two use cases that we are seeing a
lot of traction on in the market today
the first one is essentially the cloud
on-ramp which is the customers who want
to extend their enterprise into the
cloud and they essentially want a
protected I call it the protected for
smile or last mile depending on how you
look at it connectivity from the branch
into the cloud and then the second trend
that we have started seeing and we
actually are working very closely with a
couple of yeah at least three or four
customers right now on is the multi
cloud journey where they have different
points of presence on different clouds
and these clouds could be public or
private so you know we have one customer
who has data on AWS and they
the service on Google Cloud and they
want a high speed
you know multi cloud connection fabric
between these two clouds and they
essentially all they do is they extend
their enterprise infrastructure into
Amazon by deploying an ACV there to
extend the infrastructure into Google by
deploying an ECB there and then the
silver pas devant fabric things of these
as new branches in the cloud and thus
does the needful to make sure the
connectivity is guaranteed
[Music]